before we dive deep into our study of
government and politics it's worth
asking a fundamental question and that's
whether
we even need government or why do we
need government and i encourage you to
pause this video and think about this do
you think we need government and why or
do you think we don't need government
and why
okay now let's start to reason through
this a little bit and start to think
about the benefits or the pitfalls of a
government so let's say that we are in a
world without a government and this is
me right over here and at first it
sounds pretty good i have unlimited
rights here there's no one infringing on
my right i can say what i want i have
the freest possible speech
there are no laws that i could break i
have the freest possible
religion
i have no government telling me what to
practice or what i can't practice
i
have i can own
what i want
i have property i can go anywhere so i
have movement
and i also have some freedoms that those
of us who live in a government don't
typically have so i would have the
freedom to tax
others or to take from others
take
property if i'm stronger than them or if
i'm just sneakier i go in the middle of
the night i can just take their property
from them i could just settle on their
land i could
have the freedom to punish others or
imprison
others if i don't like them it doesn't
even have to be for a reason this is a
freedom that most of us don't have in
the world that we live in today but
without a government i would have this
freedom this freedom to go and take
stuff from others and to do physical
harm or imprison them or enslave them
now this might sound good to you as an
individual but remember everyone in this
government-less society would have these
same would have these same freedoms
and i especially like the ability to
have my own property and to have my own
freedom of movement but what if this
person right over here doesn't like me
to have freedom of movement and so they
say they're going to invoke look i can
punish or imprison you because i don't
like you and so they're going to
infringe on my freedom of movement by
imprisoning me or maybe i might do it to
someone else and so even though you have
all of these freedoms because everyone
else does
especially these latter few they might
be able to take some of these from you
including your freedom to live your
health your happiness
and this is well described in political
philosophy in particular you have a
gentleman by the name of thomas hobbs
who's considered one of the fathers of
political philosophy and this is what he
had to say about this state of nature
as long as men live without a common
power to keep them all in awe
they are in the condition known as war
and it is a war of every man against
every man
in war the two chief virtues are force
and fraud i can do something by physical
force or i could trick you or i could
sneak around you and take something from
you or imprison you a further fact about
the state of war of every man against
every man
in it there is no such thing as
ownership no legal control no
distinction between mine and thine
between mine and yours rather anything
that a man can get is his for as long as
he can keep it
in such a condition every man has a
right to everything even to someone
else's body
as long as this continues therefore that
is as long as every man continues to
have this natural right to everything
no man however strong or clever he may
be can be sure of living out the time
that nature ordinarily allows men to
live this was written in leviathan which
was published in 1651 so he's framing
the same thing if everyone has a right
to everything well they can infringe on
other people including their life their
health their happiness their freedom to
movement
now some of you might be skeptical of
this you might say look humans are
fundamentally good if you give them that
freedom they have a conscience they're
not going to try to do this to other
people but some of you might be able to
cite times in society where there's more
of an anarchy where actually people
might devolve and even if one or two or
three or even if a majority of the
people have a conscience and aren't
willing to imprison others and punish
people arbitrarily if even a few people
are not willing to respect other
people's rights everything might devolve
and it's worth talking about the
historical context here because this was
near the end of the english civil war
where there was chaos where people were
asking these questions well what type of
government should we have and when there
isn't a strong government all of this
chaos is really all about person versus
person it wasn't this degree of chaos
that hobbs is writing about this kind of
natural state without government but
this was a context where there was a lot
of bloodshed a lot of war and a lot of
chaos
now hobbes had a solution and this is
actually why the book was called
leviathan
he was an advocate of a very strong
central government
this keeps people in awe alludes to what
he's thinking of leviathan comes from
the old testament or the hebrew bible
it's the name of a sea monster but
hobbes thinks that a government should
be a leviathan to keep everyone in check
he wrote
when a man thinks that peace and
self-defense require it he should be
willing when others are too to lay down
his right to everything and should be
contented with as much liberty against
other men as he would allow other men
against himself
now this idea that he's talking about
this is today referred to as a social
social
contract and this term social contract
is first formally used by rousseau
another enlightenment author about a
hundred years later talking about this
willingness to give up some rights in
order to protect the ones that you
really really really want to have and
you would be giving up those rights to
some form of a government that is the
social contract between the people that
are governed and the government that
governs them
so going back to that previous example
where every person was out for
themselves what the social contract is
saying is
well look certain of these rights i
really want to keep my freedom of speech
my freedom of property my freedom to
move around my freedom to have my life
my health my happiness in order to
protect those freedoms maybe i'm willing
to give some of my other freedoms over
to a central authority as long as
everyone is willing to give these up and
this central authority that we give it
up to is a
government and the government because it
has this it uses these rights in order
to protect the other rights the ones
that i really want to keep so the
government enforces these other rights
and that's the social contract i give
away these rights in order to protect
the ones that i really really care about
and that makes sense but it still leaves
a very very big question what form
should this government take i'm willing
to engage in this social contract but
how does this government govern how are
the leaders selected what are the
constraints on that government and that
will be our focus as we study government
and politics